[موسيقى]
عذرا غسان كنفاني لقد قلت لنا ستصبح
الخيانه في يوم من الايام مجرد وجهه نظر
لكنها اصبحت القاعده والوفاء هو الاستثناء
الخارج عن الخط لقد اصبحت الخ كانت تحمل
طوابع رسميه تشتريها من اي دكان على قارعه
اي طريق لا تؤدي الى الوطن لقد اصبح
الخائن واعيا عميقا مسالما محبا للحياه
واصبح الوفي لتربه الاهل وهواء البلد
طائشا مغفلا
ارهابيا ينشر ثقافه الموت اين محل فكل
التحيه لكل الخونه الذين جعلوا الفداء
عطرا نادرا في هذا الزمان فيه من رائحه
الجنه ما لا يشمه الا العقلاء
والاصلاح الى
العناوين سفاحه الرضع نزيله سجن بخمس نجوم
في
بريطانيا ظهور مدعي المسيح الثاني
وباكورة بين نتنياهو
والسنوار جندي اسرائيلي اجرم في غزه يعلن
توبته واعتناقه
الاسلام من يفرح اكثر المحتل حين يسرح ام
المقاوم حين
يستدعى الهولوكوست تصبح هولو سكوت اذا
كانت الضحايا عربا
ومسلمين خبير امريكي شهير حكومتنا لا تصدق
الا
بالصدفه طفلان جائعان في غزه لاحد
المحسنين اولادك احق
منا مرحبا يتسم عصر الغرب المتحكم
بالاكتشافات العلميه والطبيه والتكنولوجيه
وباتساع الامراض والاوبئه وباستعراض
الطائفيه والعرقيه
والاقتصاديه وباز دواج المعايير ومزاجيه
حريه التعبير وقبل كل ذلك يتسم بانه عصر
القوي البلطجي وعصر كل مستعد لمخالفه
الفطره الانسانيه السليمه المجبول على حب
الخير والسلام مثال بسيط من بريطانيا كل
السجناء تحدد لهم زنازينهم الجماعيه او
الافراد الا سفاح حه الرضع لوسي لتبي وكان
مصلحه السجون تقول لها لك العتبه يا لتبي
حتى طردين فتخصص لها غرفه وتعطيها
مفاتيحها بحيث تستطيع ان تختلي بنفسها
للتامل ان ارادت او ان تقوم بزيارات
وتواصل مع باقي السجناء قضيه سفاحه
الاطفال البريطانيه لو سيليت بي تعود الى
الواجهه وتثير غضب اهالي الضحايا
صحيفه ديلي ميل البريطانيه قالت ان لتبي
البالغه من العمر 34 عاما مسجونه في
زنزانه خاصه تملك مفاتيحها وتدخل وتخرج
منها متى تريد كما يمكنها حبس نفسها بعيدا
عن سجناء اخرين اذا شعرت بالتهديد لتبي
ادينت بجرائم قتل عشرات الرضع والخدج داخل
الوحده التي كانت تعمل فيها بمستشفى شمال
غرب انجلترا بين عامي 2005
و6 لتبي جديد ذكر هذه المره جاستين موهن
يقطع راس ابيه مراس حدا غريب في الولايات
المتحده منفذا به حكم الاعدام وفقط لانه
موظف في حكومه جو بايدن الفيدراليه اعتقل
موهن من منزل ذويه الفخم في فورت انديانا
بولايه بنسلفانيا بعد ساعتين على بثه
المباشر الذي حمل فيه راس ابيه المقطوع
بكل فخر مقررا ان والده ذاهب الى جهنم
بسبب ولائه للحكومه الامريكيه التي تسير
بالبلاد نحو العولمه التامه والشيوعيه
وبالاقتصاد الوطني نحو الدمار المبدد
للحلم الامريكي بحسب رايه موهن الذي دعا
الشباب الامريكيين الى قتل ابائهم اذا اذا
كانوا موظفين رسميين عرض مكافاه قدرها
مليون دولار لاي شخص يتمكن من قتل شخصيه
من كبار المسؤولين جاستن موهن او المسيح
الجديد كما يصف نفسه ثلاثيني الف عده كتب
بينها ما هو بعنوان المسيح الثاني ملك
الارض المسيح الجديد هكذا يلقب الامريكي
جاستين موهن نفسه صانع المحتوى
[موسيقى]
والمنددة
وطلب من الشعب البدئ في تطهير البلاد من
اي شخص ينتمي الى الحكومه الفيدراليه
جاستين موهن ليس موصوفا بالاختلال العقلي
اقله حتى الان فله طروحاته السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والدينيه حيث يزعم انه تتمه
لرساله السيد المسيح عليه السلام وحاساه
الارهابي الصريح جاستن يتطلع الى المنافسه
على رئاسه الولايات الم حده اليمينيه
المتطرفه النقيه البياض كما يراها وسبق ان
قال جستن موهن عبر جميع صفحاته على وسائل
التواصل ان الجميع يرونه المسيح الجديد
ويريدونه ان يكون الرئيس المقبل للولايات
المتحده مقدما عرضا بمليون دولار لمن يقتل
احد رؤساء او مسؤولي مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه اف بي اي قاطع الرؤوس موهن ليس
مقطوعا من شجره في امريكا فهناك ما يسمي
نفسه بجيش الله اعلن ان يسوع ابتعثه
لحمايه الولايات المتحده من المهاجرين
المكسيكيين بطريقه سلميه حتى الان كما
يعلن حاله من التوتر الشديد تسيطر على
المنطقه الحدوديه بين ولايه تكساس
الامريكيه والتراب المكسيكي خاصه مع بروز
مجموعه جديده تسمي نفسها جيش الله
المجموعه لا يعرف عدد افرادها بدقه لكنها
تحصي المئات على الاقل حتى الان بحسب
وسائل اعلام امريكيه تتبنى خطابا دينيا
قوميا ويعتقد افرادها انهم مكلفون من الله
بحمايه امريكا غالبيتهم من انصار الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب كثيره هي الكيانات
والشخصيات التي تنسب نفسها الى الله والله
لا يحب المجرمين من جيش الله في امريكا
الى شعب الله في اسرائيل كما يزعمون لم
يقتلوا بضعه اطفال رضع ولم يكتفوا بقطع
راس رجل واحد ولم يمنعوا هجره الغرباء
اليهم بل هم الغرباء الذين هجروا اهل
الارض واسسوا مدنا على انقاض مدن ومع ذلك
لا يمنحهم العالم هذه الالقاب المعبره مثل
سفاحه الاطفال الرضع والوحش قاتل ابيه
وجيش الله النازي رغم انهم نشاوا على
ادمان مجازر الاباده الجماعيه بحق عشرات
الوف الفلسطينيين والعرب وما يزالون دوله
الاحتلال ترفض روايات شيطنتها ولها الحق
في ذلك لانها تفوقت على الشيطان نفسه الذي
وقف مندهشا منذ بدايه الحرب على غزه من
هول جرائم لا تخطر على بال ابليس يعلق ابو
خميس من خانيونس الى مدينه رفح يهرب جيش
الاحتلال من فشله ويجهد بحثا عما عجز عن
نيله في شمال القطاع
ووسطه في خطاب يشكل تمهيدا لجريمه جديده
تضاف الى مشهد الاباده الجماعيه وزير
الامن الاسرائيلي اف جالنت يعلن الاستعداد
لوصول العمليات العسكريه الى مدينه رفح
التي تضم حاليا اكثر من مليون ونصف مليون
نازح مهددين اصلا بالموت من قله الغذاء
والدواء والصحه وابسط مقومات العيش حتى في
اسرائيل ورغم شيطنهم المقاومه على مدى 55
عاما اصبحت اليوم حكومه نتنياهو وبعد بضعه
اسابيع على طوفان الاقصى تتساوى مع حركه
حماس والتقرير من التلفزيون الاسرائيلي
الرسمي
وليس من قناه
الاقصى
بط
م ر
رخ المختطف عفر كالديون وهي مش لحالها
بتساوي بين حماس وحكومه اسرائيل كل هذا
التطرف الدموي الذي يتحكم بالجهاز العصبي
لنتنياهو تتفوق عليه جينات الاجرام عند بن
كفير وزير الامن القومي
فيستبيح
بوصفها انها تحول اسرائيل الى قطيع ماعز
بنفير لم يتهمك احد بان انك ماعز بعيد
الشر عن قلبك بل لم يتهم احد الماعز بانه
يحمل الشر الذي في قلبك والماعز بكل
الوانه وفي اسوا حالاته لم نرى منه الا كل
جمال وفائده فحاشا كما ان تتشابهان بن
كفير لن نسمح بوضع تفوز فيه حماس ان مئات
قتلى الجيش الاسرائيلي ليسوا ماعزا ومئات
القتلى اليهود ليسوا ماعزا وسكان الجنوب
ليسوا ماعزا ومواطنو اسرائيل ليسوا ماعزا
وانا لست ماعزا السيد رئيس الوزراء لست
ماعزا ايضا صفقه غير شرعيه رغم ان مسجد
تميم الداري في بيت لاهيه شمال قطاع غزه
قد نخرت جدرانه وسقفه القضائ الاسرائيليه
الا ان متعتهم في اهانه مقدسات الاخرين
دفعتهم الى تفخيخ وتدبيره بشكل كامل والى
نشر الفيديو اهانه امه المليار ونصف
المليار ساكن سكونا وليس
سكنا جندي اسرائيلي وعبر بث مباشر مع ناشط
مسلم على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يفصح عن
شيء من اساليب القتل والتعذيب الذي مارسها
بفرح هستيري مع رفاقه الجنود ضد المدنيين
العزل في غزه
والصغار منهم بشكل خاص من بينها محاوله
قتل الاطفال
بالكلاب us to do terrible things we thr
in shock gres into the
houses we i can tell you
stories one time we put a doging on a
kid
الجندي الغاضب على نفسه يكشف ايضا عن
تربيه اطفال اسرائيل على عقيده ان العرب
سيكونون عبيدا لهم فهل نجحوا جزئيا يسال
بهيج
هذا الجندي الاسرائيلي لم يستطع عقله ان
يتحمل فضاع ما اقترفه مع الجيش فطردته صور
ضحاياه الى سريره وامس عاجزا عن النوم كان
يبحث عن الامان والتوبه فوجدهما في
الاسلام وفق تعبيره وقد نطق بالشهادتين
معلنا اعتناقه الدين الاسلامي
وقال لمحاور نحن في الكتاب المقدس يمكننا
قتل الاطفال والنساء والحيوانات وكل
شيء واشهد واشهد ان ان محمدا محمدا رسول
رسول
الله
الله تساءلنا في الحلقه السابقه هل سيشارك
هنود في الحرب على غزه فاتى الجواب بعرض
فيديو في وسائل التواصل لحشود المتقاطعين
امام السفاره الاسرائيليه في نيو دلهي
يطلبون بحسب تعليق هندي وفق ترجمه موقع
ترجمات تطوعهم للعمل بما فيه القتال مع
الجيش الاسرائيلي في
غه وكان احد المتطوعين واسمه يا شرما قد
قال لموقع الجزيره الانجليزي اذا اتيحت لي
الفرصه فانا على استعداد للعمل لدى الجيش
الاسرائيلي فهل ياتي الشرم الى غزه ليلحق
بمصير الجندي الفلبيني المرتزق الذي قتل
في كمين للمقاومه بغزه لتكون المكافاه
الاسرائيليه منحى ابويه الجنسيه وقد بات
عليهما الان الانضمام الى احتياط الجيش
وربما يقتلان ايضا فيحصل على قبر بعد
الجنسيه جنود الاحتلال يفرحون بسحبهم من
المعركه بنفس الدرجه التي يفرح بها
المقاومون الفلسطينيون حين يستدعون الى
القتال حتى الشهاده فماذا تقول التقارير
المؤيده
للفلسطينيين كانهم نالوا حكما بالافراج من
الجحيم هذه ليست الا فرحه جنونيه لجنود
صهاينه جاؤوا بمهمه تحقيق نصر مزعوم يتبجح
رئيس حكومتهم بانه مستمر حتى تحقيقه
يحتفلون بشكل هستيري فقط لان الضابط
اخبرهم بمغادرتهم غزه قبل ان ينالوا
نصيبهم من القتل او الاعاقه على يد
المقاومين بينما ينتظر جنوده بفارغ ما بقي
لهم من عقل لحظه فرارهم من الزحف تنتظر
زوجته ساره بفائض من الغضب ترميم مسبح
بيتها على نفقه الحكومه قبل حلول فصل
الصيف
نتنياهو المتمرد على ولي نعمه دولته في
البيت الابيض بايدن الذي اطر مكتبه هذا
الاسبوع الى نفي خبر لموقع بوليتيكو عن
شتمه بيبي هذا الاخير مطيع في المنزل
ويتخطى كل عواصف الحرب اكراما لام يا اير
بينما الجيش الاسرائيلي منغمس في معارك
غزه نتنياهو منهمك في اصلاح حمام السباحه
في منزله بملايين واكل هذا ما كشفته صحف
اسرائيليه عده والتي سلطت الضوء على ازمه
خلافات داخليه نشبت بين اعضاء فريقه
واثارت عاصفه من الجدل في الشارع
الاسرائيلي المطالب باستقالته نتنياهو
الذي يواجه تهما بالفساد كثيرا ما تعرض
لانتقادات بسبب ما ينظر اليه على انه
انفاق مفرط على اسلوب حياه مترف وواجهت
زوجته صار ايضا منذ فتره طويله مزاعم عن
العيش
الباذخ
مصطلح هولوكوست مشتق من اللغه اليونانيه
مركب من كلمتين هولو اي الكل وكوست اي
محروق فتعني هولوكوست حرق الكل وتطلق
خصوصا على ما ارتكبه النازيون بحق اليهود
في اوروبا وقد حدد يوم دولي لاحياء ذكراها
اذا كان ما تفعله اسرائيل الدافن في غزه
ليس هولوكوست
انه بلا شك هولو تفي اي دفن الكل
باليونانيه ايضا وبدعواتهم
حكم التوراه باباده
الفلسطينيين واسقاط روايه قوم عماليق في
العهد القديم عليهم اذا هولوكوست فقط اذا
كانت ضدهم اما اذا كانت شغل ايديهم فتصبح
هولو سكوت فعلى الكل ان يسكت وهذا ما
فعلته شبكه سكاي نيوز البريطانيه في لندن
التي قدمت اعتذارا رسميا لاسرائيل دون قيد
بسبب تشبيه احد صحفييها ما يرتكب في غزه
بالهول
said
said
sky the complete inpress of this
comparison and the offensive nature of
those comments sky news would like to
apologize unreserved عواصم اوربيه تمجد
قتل الافال والنساء في فلسطين ضاء معالمها
الاثريه باعلام الجهه القاتله وفي نفس
الوقت تطفئ كل شمعه تضاء لاجل حريه الشعب
الفلسطيني وحقه في الحياه الكريمه ثم
ياتينا هلبا ج من هنا وه بنك من هناك ليضع
ويقيم بكل ثقه للمستضعفين في الارض معايير
النشر والاعلام وحريه الفكر والتعبير
معالم اثريه ومبان حكوميه في جميع انحاء
اوروبا اضيئت باللونين الازرق والابيض
لاظهار التضامن مع اسرائيل في وقت تستمر
فيه التها العسكريه في سحق ما تبقى من
قطاع غزه واتهمت منظمه العفو الدوليه
السلطات الاوروبيه بتقييد الحق في
الاحتجاج بشكل غير قانوني بينما اتهم
اخرون الحكومات الغربيه بتطبيق العداله
الانتقائيه والترويج للفاش عبر منع
استنكار الجرائم
الاسرائيليه في القطع حكومه الولايات
المتحده لا تصدق الا بالصدفه اما اسرائيل
فلا تاخذ استراحه من الكذب حتى تكذب من
جديد هذا التوصيف الدقيق والجميل هو
للخبير الاقتصادي الامريكي بروفيسور جفري
سكس
نائب امريكي يشارك ببليش ومن على بعد الاف
الاميال بمحر غزه لفظيا فيقول لا يوجد
فلسطينيون مدنيون ابرياء في العالم كله
ردا على ناشطات سلام طالبنا باستئناف دعم
الاونور pictes all bab these are
innocent
pal the half million people starving to
are people that should go out there and
put a government in place that doesn't
go out att
[موسيقى]
israel
الناشطه المحترمه قالت للنائب الامريكي
انت بلا قلب فماذا يكون بعض العرب عندها
بلا قلب فقط ام بلا ماذا ايضا مع استمرار
قتل ابناء جلدتنا وتجويعهم ونحن انا وبهيج
يعني نجلس وكان على رؤوس من الطير نعيش
بالف خير تاركين لحوم اطفال امتنا لانيا
الغير منظمه اطباء بلا حدود قدرت عدد
القتلى اليومي في القطاع ب
150 كما ادانت المجازر والحصار الاسرائيلي
المطبق على القطاع واغلاق الحدود مع
مصر لقد منعنا من تقديم هذه المساعده
الانسانيه للسكان اود ان اقول اننا اليوم
نقوم بوا في مما بوسعنا فع
ل ل ت لنا ال من الناحيه
الامنيه بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم كانوا
قليلا من الليل ما
يهجعون وبالاسحار هم
يستغفرون ما شاء الله وفي اموالهم حق
السائل
والمحروم وفي الارض ايات للموقنين
[موسيقى]
والله ان صبرك على الم تضميد جراحك دون
تخدير هو ايه للناس ايضا يا حبيبي ويا
معلمنا على الصبر والاحتساب
طفل اخر يحتفي بقطع خبز عثر عليها في شمال
غزه بعد سحاب جنود الاحتلال من احد
المواقع ايش قاعد تعمل باكل خبر ليه من
وين جبته من اخر الدن من عند البحر عشان
بس ق ادو على الخبزه يعني انت خشيت مكان
قل لي مكان ما انسحبوا اليهود مع مكان
الدبابات مزوجين عشان تطلع خبز ورجينا
الخبز وريهم الخبز ورجيه زكي
متبله يعني عجبك قديش لك ما اكلتش خبز
قديش لك ما اكلت خ والله يمكن شهر ونص ما
اكلتش خبز ولا دكت
لقيت اول مره تذوقه طب تبيعه لا ولا بكل
المصاري ولا بكل الدنيا
بتوحش روح كل طالعه معك اعطيها كمان واحده
اعطيها كمان واحده صحه وعافيه يا قلبي
اخيرا واحد من الاباء المكافحين في غزه لا
ينام ليله بحثا عن رقمه لاطفاله فيعود
اليهم بحفنه طحين اختلط بالتراب بعد تسربه
من احدى الشاحنات
يحدث ذلك ليس من فقر لدى المسلمين والعرب
اتحدث عن الفقر بالمال فقط بالمال الليي
من الساعه حده في الليل طالع علشان اجيب
لقمه العيش انا مقاول يا عمي وقد حالي زي
ما انتم شايفين عشان اجيب لقمه العيش اللي
من الساعه واحده طالع قسما بالله لا في
طحين ولا في اكل ولا في شرب حسبي الله
ونعم الوكيل بس مش اكثر ولا اقل هي اطلع
طحين خربان قاعد باكل والله هييه قسما
بالله طحين خربان هيه خربان طحين من
الشارع لميته باكله في رمله ه في رمله
باكله وينكم يا
عرب ختاما سمعنا في دروس السيره النبويه
الشريفه قصص الايثار العظيمه لال بيت
الرسول وصحابته رضي الله عنهم اجمعين هذا
ترك ماء الشرب لغيره رغم عطشه المميت وذاك
مقيم قدم نصف ماله لمهاجر لكنهم كانوا
رجالا ونساء كبارا اما قصه الاثار
المعاصره التاليه فهي لطفلين يشكوان البرد
والجوع في غزه يشتهي ان كل شيء بدءا
بالخبز والمعكرونه لكنهما يقولان لاحد
المحسنين اليهما كفاك يا سيدي فاولا دك
اولى منا الى اللقاء ايش هذا اللي مش
سقعان انت والله والله برض وين وين في خي
متش انتم في مدرسه راعه مدرسه رابعه ايش
نفسكم والله في كل شي ن في كل شي كل شي كل
شي كل شي كل شي والله اعطيك تضحك قبل طيب
انت نفسك نفسك في الاندومي صح طب هي وانت
ايش نفسك في الاندومي خلاص هيك نفسكم تمام
لا احنا مش ما خلصنا وانت نفسك بف وانت في
هذه كمان كمان كمان كمان وانت هذا
وانت ه كمان لا خلاص مش طمعين مش طمعين
لكن انا بقول لكم ابشروا خيرا هذه تشتروا
فيها نفسك
فلا الاولادي مش ابدا انتم اولى من
الاولادي على فكره اقوللك ليش لانه انت
اودي وحياه
الله
ه